hey guys my name is Jonah and welcome to
the fifth episode of my flappy bird
series today we'll be talking about
shaders specifically how we can load
them for use in our game firstly what's
a shadow a shader is a bunch of code a
program that runs on our GPU rather than
our CPU basically shaders allow us to
program the graphics card which as you
can imagine is immensely useful for
graphics there are two types of shaders
in OpenGL vertex and fragment shaders
vertex shaders are used for every vertex
of every object we render whereas
fragment shaders are used for every
fragment or basically pixel of objects
with render this will make much more
sense in future episodes when we
actually write these shaders there are
actually more types of shaders such as
geometry and tessellation shaders but
we'll only need vertex and fragment
shaders for this game and most others
let's go ahead and collapse our math
package we're not going to need to work
with it right now let's create a new
class and put it into a new package util
this stands for utility and thus this
package will hold all of our utility
classes that is classes that help us
perform common operations we're going to
write our shaders as separate files so
we'll need a way to load in all the text
from a file let's create a file utils
class that will do just that I'm gonna
make a private constructor here so that
we can't instantiate this class since
it's going to be completely static
meaning we never have any need for
instances then what we need to do is
write a method that will convert a file
that we give it into a string so we'll
call the method load of string firstly
let's create the result string that
we'll be returning and then create a
buffer grader object that will read our
actual file so we'll create a new file
rated with the file path that resides in
the parameter for this method we'll need
to import these two classes so let's hit
ctrl shift or or command shift on Mac to
organise our imports as you can see with
what our class is imported now we still
have an error however since creating a
new bufferedreader object throws an
exception
we'll simply surround it with the try
and catch great the way that we're going
to read our file is line by line so we
need to create a string that will hold a
temporary line that we're reading I'm
gonna call this string buffer but
another suitable name might be something
like line now we need some sort of loop
to read every line there is in the file
we're loading we can use either a for
loop or a while
but I'll use the latter because it's
slightly easier to understand what I've
written here is the condition for the
while loop is essentially as long as red
line doesn't equal null the red line
method will actually advance to the next
line after it's done which is why we
need to set buffer equal to red adult
red line since next time we call that
method it will read the next line if it
returns null it means that on any more
lines to read we finish reading the file
inside the while loop we simply need to
append the buffer to our result string
along with the newline character so that
we can separate lines if needed finally
we'll close our reader since we're done
with it and release the file we just
read these two methods through i/o
exceptions so let's change our file not
found exception to an i/o exception
since the i/o exception class includes a
file not found exception if you want to
handle these separately or actually do
something if an exception is thrown go
ahead
i'ma leave it like this for simplicity's
sake we'll return our result and we're
done that's all there is to file utils
for now so now that we have a way to
load a file as a string we can make a
shader utils class that will actually
load our shaders into OpenGL will pop
shader details into the utility of
course
primarily we're going to need OpenGL 2.0
methods for this class so let's import
GL 2-0 statically this class will also
have a private constructor firstly let's
make a create method this will create a
program containing our two shaders
vertex and fragment based on a string
containing the source code that will
provide firstly we'll need to create a
new opengl program a program is a
collection of different types of shaders
that will work together so in this case
it will contain our vertex and fragment
shader once we've got our program let's
create the actual vertex and fragment
shaders these three and many other
OpenGL create methods will return
integers which contain the ID of what we
just created these IDs can later be used
to modify various data that we've
created or put it to use now that we've
created two shaders we need to pass in
the source code to OpenGL so that it can
be compiled most things in this method
will be done in pairs for both the
vertex and fragment shader so we'll run
the GL shader source twice for each
shader and passing the appropriate
string of source code
next we'll compile both of these shaders
now we'll attach both traders to our
program link the program and validate it
finally we can return it and our method
is complete since shaders consist of
source code it would be really useful
for us to see any syntax errors that we
made when writing the shader these
errors will obviously stop our program
from being created and what we'll get is
just a general OpenGL error to do that
after we compile our shader we'll check
to see if the compiled status is equal
to false gl false is OpenGL version of
false and we'll need to import that it's
located in GL 1:1 but instead of
importing that entire class we can just
go ahead and import just the GL false
constant since that's all we'll need
now back in our if statement will print
out an error message of our own and then
the actual shader info log with a length
of 2048 characters which should be
enough using system dot error rather
than systems are out will yield read
text and eclipses console and should
generally be used for printing error
messages let's copy this if statement
and adjust it for our fragment shader
fantastic now we'll get really helpful
error messages for our shadows since we
want to create our shaders from files
and not just strings let's create
another short method the text in a file
path for each of our shaders loads the
files and strings and then runs the
create method to create the shader
program there we go nice and simple all
we have to do to use this code is simply
call shader utils dot load specify a
file path for our vertex and fragment
shader and we have our shader ready to
use we'll get rid of this code for now
since it was just an example thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoyed this
video as always it like is greatly
appreciated next episode we'll be
covering texture loading goodbye